regulations require that product labels
on containers of food that are available
for sale to the public accurately state
the amount of food in those containers
specifically if milk containers are
labeled to have 128 fluid ounces and the
mean number of fluid ounces of milk in
the containers is at least 128 the milk
processor is considered to be in
compliance with the regulations the
filling machines can be set to the
labeled amount variability in the
filling process causes the actual
contents of milk containers to be
normally distributed a random sample of
12 containers of milk was drawn from the
milk processing line in a plant and the
amount of milk in each container was
recorded
the sample mean and standard deviation
of this sample of 12 containers of milk
were 127.2 ounces and 2.1 ounces
respectively
is there sufficient evidence to conclude
that the packaging plant is not in
compliance with the regulations provides
statistical justification for your
answer so pause this video and see if
you can have a go at it
all right now let's do this together so
first let's say what we're talking about
so let me define mu and this is going to
be the mean
mean amount
amount
of
milk
in population
population
of
containers
containers
at the plant that we care about and so
then we can set up our hypotheses our
null hypothesis over here is that we are
in compliance we could say that the mean
for our population of containers is
actually 128 that's our minimum we need
to be in compliance and that our
alternative hypothesis is that we are
not in compliance so that's that our
mean the true population mean is less
than
128 fluid ounces and so this is a
situation where we are
not in compliance
not in
compliance
compliance
in
the alternative hypothesis now if you're
going to do a significance test you need
to set a significance level so let's do
that over here
significance level and if you haven't
noticed i'm doing i'm trying to do in
this video what would be expected of you
on a test and this is an actual question
from an ap exam so our significance
level here i'll just pick it to be 0.05
because well that's a fairly typical one
and since they didn't give it one to us
it's important to set one ahead of time
and now we want to check our conditions
for inference so let me do that over
here conditions
conditions
for
inference and this is to feel good that
the sample that we're using to make our
inference to do our significance test
that it's a reasonable one to make make
inferences from and so the first one is
our the random condition
and do we meet that
well they tell us here it's a random
sample of 12 containers of milk if i was
doing this on the ap exam i would write
it out here so i would say
in the passage or in question
in the question
they say
they say
a random
a random
sample
of
12 and then they go on to say more
things and so i would say that meets
condition
meets
condition
now the next one we want to care about
is our normal condition and this is to
feel good that our sampling distribution
is roughly normal now there's a couple
of ways that we could do that one is if
our sample size is greater than 30 or
greater than or equal to 30 then we say
okay our sampling distribution is going
to be roughly normal but in this
situation our sample size n so sample
size
sample size
is less than 30
but but there's another way to meet the
normal condition and that's if the
underlying parent data is normally
distributed and they actually say it
right over here variability in the
filling process causes the actual
contents of milk to be normally
distributed so we could say in passage
in passage says
and let's see i could quote part of this
so actual contents
actual
contents
and dot dot dot normally distributed
normally
distributed
so that meets condition
meets
condition
and then the last condition we want to
think about is the independence
condition
independence
and this is to feel
good that the observations that the
individual observations in our sample
can be considered to be roughly
independent now one way is if they were
sampling with replacement which they're
not doing here looks like they took all
12 containers at once but another way is
if this is less than 10 percent of the
overall population then you could say
okay they're going to you can view them
as roughly independent and so you say
didn't
didn't
sample
with replacement
with replacement
but
but
assume
assume
that
12 is less than 10 percent
of the population in that case you would
meet condition
meet
this condition as well
so it looks like we are we've met these
three conditions that we need to make
for inference or we can assume we've
done it they haven't given us any
information to the contrary and so now
what we can do is calculate a t
statistic and then from that calculate
our p value compare our p value to our
significance level and see what kind of
conclusions we can make and so our t
statistic right over here and once again
if at any point you're inspired and if
you haven't done so already try to do it
on your own our t statistic is going to
be our sample
mean
minus the assumed mean from the null
hypothesis and let me since i'm
introducing this notation this little
sub zero i'll say that's the assumed
assumed mean
from
my null hypothesis so i'll do that and
then i'll divide ideally if i was doing
a z statistic i would divide by the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution
of the sample mean
which is often known as the standard
error of the mean but the whole reason
why i'm doing a t statistic is well i
don't know exactly what that is but i
could estimate the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution of the sample
mean using
the sample standard deviation divided by
the square root of n and once again it's
always good if you're doing this on a
test to explain what n is or what some
of these things are if you're using
standard notation it's people might
assume what they are but if you have
time on these tests you can always
explain more of what these actual
variables are but in this case this is
going to be 127.2
that is our sample mean
minus our assumed mean from our null
hypothesis minus 128
all of that over our sample standard
deviation is 2.1
divided by the square root of 12. and so
this is going to be approximately equal
to
got a calculator out here
and so
we have seen the numerator we have 127.2
minus
128
and then we're going to divide that by
i'll do another parenthesis 2.1
divided by
the square root of
12 and then
let me close
my parentheses did i type that in
correctly yeah that looks right click
enter and so this is negative i'll say
it's approximately negative
1.32
so negative 1.32
and now we can figure out our p-value
our
p-value which is the same thing as the
probability of getting a t-statistic
this low or lower so we could say t
is less than or equal to negative 1.32
is equal to so i'll get my calculator
back out
and so here what i would use is i would
use
the
cumulative distribution function for t
statistics so that's that right over
there
and so
i do care about the left tail so i care
about the area under the curve from
negative infinity up to and including
negative 1.32 so let's do negative
negative
1.32
and then my degrees of freedom well it's
going to be my sample size minus 1. my
sample size was 12 so that minus 1 is
11. and then i do paste
and so i have this
tcdf from negative e 99 to negative 1.32
comma 11. and actually you'd want to
write this down on your exam if you were
doing it just so they know where you got
that from and so this is
this is equal to
[Music]
0.107 so let me write it this is
approximately
0.107
and it's important to say how you
calculated this so used
used t
c
d f and we went from negative 1
times 10 to the 99th power and we went
up to negative
1.32
and then we had 11 degrees of freedom to
get this result right over here
and it also might be good practice to
draw your t-distribution right over here
so that's our t-distribution that's the
mean of our t-distribution so we say
that this is the area that we care about
so that is
that right over there just to make sure
people know what we're talking about and
so here now we're ready to make a
conclusion we can compare this to our
significance level and so we can say
since
since
0.107 is greater than our significance
level is greater than 0.05
which is alpha
we
fail
we fail
to reject
reject the null hypothesis and so let's
just make sure we read their question
right is there sufficient evidence to
conclude that the packaging plant is not
in compliance with the regulations and
so another way of saying is there is not
there is not
sufficient
sufficient i'm gonna have to scroll down
a little bit i'm trying to squeeze it on
the page but i'm gonna have to go down
there is not
sufficient evidence
sufficient evidence to conclude
to to conclude
that
the
plant
is
not
in
compliance with regulations
and then
we are done